The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm going
to get started.
And after a couple of minutes
there will be an announcement.
So today's lecture
will begin by looking
at the singlet state
for a few minutes,
a couple of its properties.
And then we go into this
Einstein-Podolsky-Rosen
argument.
We'll talk about
what they said, what
they wanted to criticize
quantum mechanics for.
And then we'll go
through the answer
given by Bell that
actually demonstrated
that Einstein, Podolsky,
and Rosen were wrong.
And after we'll do
those Bell inequalities,
we'll close this chapter
on quantum states of spins
and begin our treatment
of angular momentum.
So I want to remind you
of a couple of things.
We've been discussing this
so-called singlet state.
Plus, minus.
For the second particle,
minus minus, plus.
First and second particle.
This state.
A few things we've discovered
about this state--you've been
working with it.
We calculated its z-component
of total angular momentum,
the angular momentum
of the first particle
and the second particle.
And it was 0.
The x-component was 0.
This y-component is 0.
In fact it doesn't have
any total angular momentum.
So this state is rotationally
invariant, we say,
because it doesn't
have angular momentum.
You did very fine
in the homework
that the state is in fact
rotationally invariant.
Now this state is a
very interesting state.
It's one of those
entangled states
that we discussed
last time when we
were talking about
teleportation and Bell states.
And apart from
that, it's a state
that is not hard to
realize physically.
In fact, it typically
takes place, for example,
in reactions in decays
of certain particles.
For example, pi 0 can
decay into two photons.
Then the two photos can be
in the state of total angular
momentum 0.
But more precisely, since we're
talking spin-1/2 particles,
if you have a meson
called an eta 0,
it's a interacting particle
of strong interactions.
A meson decays rather quickly
into a mu-plus plus a mu-minus.
Actually it decays into
other things as well.
So it decays into two
spin-1/2 particles.
And this particle has
0 angular momentum.
It's a scalar.
It's not spinning.
And therefore, if
these two particles
go into a state of 0
orbital angular momentum,
conservation of angular
momentum implies
that these two particles are
in the state of this form that
has 0 spin angular momentum,
total spin angular momentum.
So the realization of an
entangled state like that
is fairly common
and fairly easy.
So you have a decay
of this form and you
get particles that are
entangled this way.
You showed that
this state actually
could be a written as one
over square root of 2, n-plus,
n-minus, 1, 2, minus
n-minus, n-plus, 1, 2.
Precisely because this
invariant and the rotations,
you could use instead of the
plus-minus basis, any basis n.
For any direction n,
you have this state.
Now we'll talk about
the probability
that is of interest to us.
We'll write to this symbol,
probability to get a plus,
say, b plus.
And this means that
probability to get particle--
let me see-- to find the
first particle-- particle
with spin along a so that
this first particle to be
in the state a plus.
And the second
particle-- particle
will spin along-- along b.
So in this state, b plus.
Now that looks--
this calculation
of this probability-- So you're
going to do some measurement.
And you ask, what
is the probability
I find the first particle in
this direction, second particle
pointing in this direction?
It may look like a somewhat
non-trivial calculation.
And it is.
But if you use the fact
this the state over
there-- because we're asking for
this probability on this state.
We're going to be
talking about this state.
So if you put the state and you
write the state in the form,
you pick one of the
two vectors, say, a.
Well, the state is a-plus,
a-minus, 1, 2, minus a-minus,
a-plus.
Because I could choose
n to be anything.
So might this well choose one
of the two vectors to be a.
And then you ask what
is the probability
to find first
particle in this state
and second particle
in this state?
Well, when somebody tells
you, what is the probability
to find a particle
in a state, you
put that state into--
you sandwich your psi
with that state.
And this overlap, which is
a number, you square it.
So we're going to do
the same thing here.
So what is this probability?
Probability to find
a plus, b plus,
would be the absolute value.
And then we put here a
plus in the first state.
Tensor product, we could say.
Well, b plus in
the second state.
And we should put-- because
this is what we want to find,
the state on the tensor
product that we're looking for.
And we put the psi here.
So we must put the 1 over
square root of 2 times
the a-plus 1, a-minus 2,
minus a-minus 1, a-plus 2.
So [? overlap ?] time, well,
we go 1 with 1, 2 with 2.
So well, a-plus with
a-plus will give me 1.
b-plus with a-minus,
I don't know.
Second term, a-plus
with a-minus gives me 0.
So this term is irrelevant.
I just need this.
So the a-plus with
the a-plus gives me 1.
I have the 1 over
square root of 2 here.
And I must close
this and square.
I forgot to write that.
So what is this probability?
A-plus, b-plus is equal to-- the
1 over square root becomes 1/2.
And then all we have left
is b-plus with a-minus.
In the second state space, in
the particle 2 state space,
the label doesn't matter
at the end of the day
now that we've
disentangled the 1 and 2.
So it's b-plus a-minus.
I don't have to
write that it's 2, 2.
Or you can write it.
And it's this squared.
So it's simplified a lot but
not quite yet the answer.
What we need here is the overlap
between these two spin states.
And I remind you that when
you had any arbitrary spin
states with n and n prime,
long, long ago, homework three
or four, something like
that, you calculated
the overlap between
these two spin states.
And the answer
was that you would
take cosine of
1/2 of the angle--
if there is an angle gamma.
The overlap between
the spin states
squared was cosine
squared of 1/2 the angle.
So here we have the vector
a, see, the vector b.
Here is the vector
a-minus, a-minus direction.
And if we call this theta ab,
this is pi minus theta ab.
So this should be
1/2 cos squared
1/2 of pi minus theta ab.
1/2 cosine square
of half of the angle
between the two
relevant vectors.
So this is cosine of pi
over 2 minus theta over 2.
That's sine squared
of theta ab over 2.
So here it is.
It's our calculation
of this thing.
It's a neat formula that we're
going to need later today.
So one more comment
before a little stop,
if b is equal to minus a.
Now in that case you should
be in luck because precisely
what's happening here
is that if one spin is
along the plus
direction the other
has to be along the minus
direction, whichever
you choose.
So in order to have that a
be in plus and b be in plus,
well, this first
term would do it.
a is in plus, the
first particle.
Here, no.
And b, which is minus
a, would be in plus.
So the probably should be 1/2.
So if b is minus a, the angle
theta ab is equal to pi.
And the probability of
ab is 1/2, correctly.
And it's 1/2 because half
of the cases a is in plus.
The other cases, a is in minus.
So the other case, for example,
that could be interesting is,
what is the probability
that the first particle is
in z-plus and the second
particle is in x-plus?
Well, these two vectors
form 90 degrees.
So you should have 1/2
of the sine of half that.
So that should give you 1/2 of
the sine squared of pi over 4.
And it's 1/2, then it's 1
over square root of 2, that's
another 1/2.
So it's one quarter,
for example.
OK, I went long
enough for a moment.
There's an announcement
that [? Preshanth ?] wants
to make so please listen to him.
[? PRESHANTH: Hi ?] I'm back
for another announcement.
So tonight, the MIT SPS
is going to be holding
its fall UROP
lightning lectures.
So if you don't have a UROP
it's a great opportunity for you
to come and see what other
research your classmates are
doing in physics.
If you do have a UROP,
I would encourage
you to come as well because
you can actually come and share
your stories about the
technical content of what
you're doing in your UROP.
It's 7:30 this evening
in the PCR 8329.
There will be free food,
so please join us then.
And see you all then.
Thanks.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
All right.
So, this was the introduction
to what we really
need to do today.
So before we get started,
are there any questions
on what we've done so far?
On these properties of
this entangled state?
So this is a measurement
of an entangled state.
These two particles could have
flown away a big distance.
Two observers, one tries to
see what is the probability.
The first observer
sees the spine
pointing in some direction.
The other observer sees the spin
pointing in another direction.
It's a the natural
question which
can be done experimentally.
And we've calculated
that answer.
Now so let's begin
with this EPR story.
Now, you've seen some of
EPR last semester in 804.
The only complication with
that is that you really
needed to have these mathematics
to appreciate it completely.
So this second
look at EPR should
be fairly complete in that we
won't leave almost anything out
of the story.
There are many ways of doing
EPR and essentially these Bell
inequalities, which is the
really non-trivial thing that
comes after that.
So some are in the
homework, some elaborations.
And probably in recitation
later in the course
we'll see a little more.
But it all begins with a
strange thing, the kind of thing
that you wouldn't expect
people in physics to discuss.
And it's the point
of this so-called--
Einstein, Polosky, and
Rosen wrote a paper.
And they talked
about local realism.
Now, that sounds
like philosophy.
And for awhile people
thought, well, this
is interesting, but undecidable.
Can't really do
anything with it.
So what is local realism?
Now, again, not being
exactly physics,
it's not all that easy
to say what it is.
And people discussed that.
But some notion of
it is fairly clear.
The notion is that this reflects
something-- it's basically
two assumptions about
measurement results.
So you measure something
and obtain a number.
And the first assumption,
one, is that these measurement
results correspond to
some aspects of reality.
Just said like that it
seems a little funny.
That you measure something,
if get some numbers,
because that was something
real about this object,
it had this property.
And so measurement corresponds
to some aspect of reality.
So measurements-- assumptions
about measurement results.
So measurements.
m, correspond to some
aspect of reality.
Two, the measurements that
you do in you lab are not
affected whatsoever
by the measurements
that somebody else is doing
at the same time at the moon.
There's no time
for the information
of what that result in the
moon has given to reach you.
So at that instant of time,
what they are doing at the moon
doesn't affect the result
of your experiment.
So it's measurement is
independent of actions
performed at a distant
location at the same time.
Now to Einstein and Polosky
and Rosen-- but Einstein
was very vocal-- Physics
must satisfy that.
It's kind of sad
I think, actually.
The person that managed to see
through and discover how nature
works at so many deep levels--
the photoelectric effect,
special relatively,
general relativity--
somehow became convinced
that this had to be true.
And unfortunately, he was wrong.
Or fortunately, I guess.
It's not worth trying
to qualify that.
But these two things that
seem just so reasonable
are just not true.
This one, measurements
correspond
to some aspect of
reality-- you see,
you have a Stern-Gerlach
apparatus, you throw a spin,
it goes up.
You say it ended
up with spin up.
Well, Einstein would say
it always had spin up.
It was a reality about that
object, at it had spin up.
You just didn't know.
You did the experiment
to you discovered it.
So the thing that people
try to do in order
to understand this concept,
that it corresponds to something
having to do with
the reality, is
that you admit that
half of the particles
go up and half go down.
But you say, actually,
there's something
about these particles
you don't know.
And if you knew that, you
would just be able to tell.
This is a particle
that has spin up.
And it will go up.
But in quantum mechanics,
we have abandoned that.
We've said these particles here
are a superposition of a state
up and a state down.
And there's nothing definitely
up about this particle
or definitely down.
So the way people do
this, to correspond
to this aspect of reality
that you don't know,
is by introducing what is
called hidden variables.
Some things that
allow you-- there's
something hidden about this spin
particle that you don't know.
But if you knew it you
would know exactly how
it's going to come out through
this Stern-Gerlach experiment.
And you say, well, that
sounds fairly untestable.
But the fact is that it's not.
Now, so this is
implemented, this assumption
is-- when people try to
modify quantum mechanics,
they use what is called
hidden variables.
Some things that you don't
know about the particle,
but if you knew, you would
see that in fact this particle
has spin up.
This second is in some ways even
more disturbing because we got
accustomed to the
idea that, locally,
simultaneous things
that cannot be reached--
events that cannot talk to each
other via the exchange of light
cannot effect each other.
So simultaneous things
that's happened far away
can't effect each other.
So this also sounds
very reasonable.
But that's also wrong.
And there's the obvious
question, so if this is wrong,
can you send information
faster than the speed of light?
And people looked at
it in many, many ways.
And it's very interesting.
And we could discuss that.
But it would take us
long, so I will leave it
to, maybe, the recitations,
maybe other forums.
But here, actually,
there's no contradiction,
no way of finding real
information going faster
than the speed of light,
even though things
far away at the same
time can affect you.
So two very
interesting things that
seemed very dangerous to discard
but turned out to be wrong.
So this is what EPR did.
And they made some
thought experiments
that we're going to
review to some degree
and see if we can discard
these assumptions.
So that's what we're
going to do now.
We're going to try
to understand that.
Now, if you're interested in
what hidden variables are,
my discussion will not
use hidden variables.
Although they are
kind of implicit,
you will see, as I
state some things.
I'm basically going to be
explicit on the fact that
things, [? the ?] [? real ?]
[? facts, ?] as Einstein would
like you to think.
And we'll try to see if those
real qualities about particles
get us in trouble.
So let's begin and try to
discuss this first experiment.
You see observer one, Alice
and Bob again, if you want.
Alice is going to
measure about the z-axis.
Bob is going to measure
about the z-axis.
And therefore, if Alice finds
spin up, Bob finds spin down.
If Alice finds spin
down, Bob finds spin up.
And that's a correlation.
And it's very interesting.
But Einstein, Bell, and
Polosky would say, look,
it's not all that interesting.
There's nothing all that
mysterious happening here.
EPR would says, the
pairs that you've built,
the so-called
entangled pairs, are
pairs of particles with
definite spins-- spin
directions, spin vectors.
So what you have
built, EPR would say,
if you have here particle
1 and particle 2--
I'm going to list
the properties.
Suppose you have a
particle 1, you've created.
Einstein would say
some particle 1s
with spin up in z and particle
2 with spin down in z.
Or you've created particles
1 with spin down in z
and particle 2
with spin up in z.
And you've created [INAUDIBLE]
50% of the particles
are of this type, of the pairs.
And 50% of the pairs
are of this kind.
So don't tell me all this
superposition hocus pocus.
Half of your pairs, one
particle has spin up,
one particle has spin down.
The other 50% of your
pairs, particle one is down,
the other particle is up.
No wonder they're correlated.
You get plus, gets minus.
Get minus, get plus.
What is the probability
that you get plus?
50%.
What is the probability
you get minus?
50%.
Everything is reproduced.
Mystery over.
No quantum superpositions.
OK?
There's no mistake here.
No mathematical mistake.
You're saying that the
particle has a definite spin.
You maybe not know it.
But we say, look,
your particles in fact
have a definite spin, z-plus
and z-minus and those things.
And this is where hidden
variables would come along.
You would say, well, if you
have the particle 1, it's spin
is a function of some hidden
variable that you don't know.
But if you knew
it, you would know
what the spin is because
it has a definite spin.
You don't know what is
the hidden variable.
But as a function of
the hidden variable
the spin is known, definite,
not a superposition,
nothing like that.
It's a very aggressive
attack on quantum mechanics
and something that
troubled people.
And in fact fascinates
people even up to now
because the idea,
these kind of things
are really absolutely wrong.
It's very shocking.
Perhaps the second even more
shocking because, by now
may be you're accustomed
to all kinds of variables
that are a little more
detached from reality.
You have electromagnetic fields.
And they forced you to
learn about potentials
that seem to be a
little more abstract.
And similarly here.
So no problem at all.
So people say, OK, this
is a simple situation.
But it may be that we're
going to do more measurements.
And we're going to consider two
directions that are different.
Maybe Alice has two
Stern-Gerlach machines,
one that measures about z
and one the measures about x.
And Bob has also to
Stern-Gerlach machines,
one of the measures about z
and one that measures about x.
And they are going to
ask different questions.
Because we know the
spin, how it transforms.
So getting those results
right with two directions
is going to be a little
more interesting.
So we're going to try measuring
in two possible directions.
Both A and B, Alice and Bob,
can measure in two directions, z
and x.
And Einstein would say, look,
you can measure in z and in x.
To avoid confusion, let's not
talk about one measurement
after another.
Particle comes, you measure
in z or you measure in x.
And realism says
that you don't know
what you will get because maybe
there are hidden variables.
But each particle
has a definite answer
if you ask what is the
z direction of the spin
and has a definite
answer if you ask
what is the x-component
of the spin.
Definite answers, real
answers, realism again.
So I'm going to
label the particles.
For example, this is a label
for a particle z-plus, x-minus.
This particle labeled
like that would be such
that if you measure its spin
in the z direction, it's plus.
If you measure the spin in
the x direction, it's minus.
So measured in z, it is up.
Measured in x, it is down.
These are the kind of particles
that EPR would say exist.
It's not that you
got a particle out
and it's in some
strange entangled state.
These particles are flying away.
They're not talking
to each other anymore.
And this particle, since you
can measure in two directions,
there's some reality,
and the measurements
correspond to reality,
so there are attributes.
And this particle is classified
by having these attributes.
If you measure z, plus.
If you measure x, minus.
So how about this situation.
Well, let me make a list now.
Particles 1 and particle 2.
And this would be the list
that EPR would do for you.
EPR comes along and says,
look, here's what you're doing.
Particle 1, suppose
it's a z-plus, x-plus.
Well, in your beams, actually,
when particle 1 is that,
your other particles
are z-minus, x-minus.
So if particle 1
is of this type,
particle 2 is of this type.
That way, EPR protect themselves
because they say, look,
if you measure z-plus
and you measure z-minus,
you get correlation.
If you get plus and plus,
you get correlation as well.
Now there can be particles
in z-plus, x-minus.
This will go with
a z-minus, x-plus.
There could be a
particle z-minus, x-plus,
and this as z-plus, x-minus.
And there could be
particle z-minus, x-minus,
z-plus, x-plus.
So there are four
cases, four types
of particles they say
have been produced.
And 25% of pairs
are of this form.
25% of pairs are of this,
25 of this, and 25 of this.
So you could ask some
questions to EPR.
What is the probability
that you get z-plus for 1
and z-minus on 2.
Well, z-plus on 1,
it's these two cases.
And z-minus on 2,
well, those two cases.
So this is 50% of the times.
So it's 1/2 that probability.
It's correct.
That's what we would predict
from an entangled state
viewpoint.
But let's ask something mixed.
Let's see if we get in trouble.
P of z-plus on 1, and
let's say x-plus on 2.
Well, z-plus on 1 and
x-plus on 2, that's not it.
This case.
z-plus on one, x-plus on 2.
25% of the times, one 1/4.
This was the probability
we calculated.
So you tried with one direction.
You don't need quantum
mechanics to produce a result.
You try with two directions,
you don't need quantum mechanics
to get the result.
So people got stuck and
they said, well, maybe it's
undecidable.
Maybe this is philosophy.
Maybe this is something.
And people had to wait for Bell.
He said I'm going to
try three directions.
Now, three directions
makes a big difference.
This is the first time
it really goes wrong.
So it's kind of surprising,
perhaps, at some level.
But this is subtle stuff.
So it takes a while before
you find something wrong.
You're talking about
showing Einstein it's wrong,
so that's not so easy.
So three directions.
So particles are going to be
of types-- EPR would say, look,
I'm going to use
the same strategy.
I'm going to say that particles
have three attributes now.
They're all physical.
They correspond to reality.
Because if you measure in
either of three directions,
they have to have
an answer for that.
So here's a label
for a particle.
And for example,
a-plus, b-minus, c-plus.
So if you measure, it would
give spin in a direction
plus h bar over 2.
Spin in the b direction minus--
well, in the b direction
would give you
minus h bar over 2.
Spin in the c direction would
give you plus h bar over 2 .
So we're not measuring
simultaneously.
We're just asking, well,
you take a particle,
do a measurement,
and see what you get.
And we're always going to
be asking for probabilities
of this kind, probably that the
first particle is doing this
and the second is doing that.
Well, EPR would start
now with particles
again, particle 1, particle 2.
And populations.
So let's list quickly
the particles.
a-plus, b-plus, c-plus.
Then you will go
a-plus, b-plus, c-minus.
Then you've done the
c-plus, c-minus here.
You go for two more.
A-plus, b-minus, c-plus.
a-plus, b-minus, c-minus.
I was supposed to
fit four more there.
Can I?
Well, I will try. a-minus.
Now you've done all
the four a-pluses
so you need four a-minuses.
Then you have b-plus, b-plus,
b-minus, b-minus, c-plus,
c-minus, c-plus, c-minus.
I got all, I think.
And particle two of
course is correlated.
You would say, well, I
don't need to write it.
But it helps seeing what's going
on so I'll write it. a-minus,
b-minus, c-minus,
a-minus, b-minus,
c-plus, a-minus-- let's use
bars here-- a-minus, b-plus,
c-minus, a-minus, b-plus,
c-plus, a-plus, b-minus,
c-minus, a-plus, b-minus,
c-plus, a-plus, b-plus,
c-- this one is minus
so it's plus here.
We're done.
Lots of labels.
And you could say,
well, maybe you
want to put 1/8 in each of them.
But actually the argument
is more interesting.
It doesn't need you have
to try to put fractions.
So let's consider that there's
a total number of particles
N, which is N1 plus up to N8.
And here are N1 of this,
N2 of this, N3 of this,
N4 of this, N5, N6, N7, and N8.
Let's see how--
All right, so we have that.
Well, it takes
imagination to see
how you're going to run
into some contradiction.
So what is the basis
for the contradiction?
Somehow this formula, which
is really quantum mechanical
must eventually go wrong
with all these attempts
to deny that the world
is quantum mechanical.
So we could split again those
particles into equal fractions.
But there's no need to do that.
And it's clearer if you don't.
So you try to combine the three
directions into one equation.
So one way to do that
would be to say, OK,
what is the probability that
you get a-plus and b-plus?
So this is for the
particle number 1.
And this is particle number 2.
So then you must
look at the table
and say which one's do that.
Well, you need
a-plus in the first
so it's one of the
first four rows.
And b-plus in the second.
So actually, it's these two
cases, N3 and N4, over N.
We want to involve
three directions.
So let's go for another one.
P of a-plus with c-plus.
Let's see how much is that.
Again, this is for
the first particle.
This is for the second particle.
So I must look at
the first four rows.
And see that you have an a-plus.
First part is in a-plus
for the first four rows.
But the second
should be in c-plus
and that is cases N2 and N4.
So we get N2 plus
N4 here over N.
Well, we've involved
this a with b, a with c.
How about involving b with c?
So I'll put c-plus,
b-plus, for example.
OK c-plus, b-plus.
I must look at c-pluses,
and b-pluses, no.
C-plus and b-plus, yes.
N3 is there, which is good
because it already was there.
And which else?
c-plus and b-plus.
c-plus, no.
c-plus here b-plus, yes.
N7.
Now N3 plus N4 is less than
N3 plus N7 plus N4 plus N2.
You see you have N3 and N4.
And now I add whatever
N7 and N2 are.
And that's then an
inequality because it's
going to be more cases.
Now I divide by N. So
you obtain an inequality
that P of a-plus,
b-plus is less than
or equal than N3 plus
N7 and N4 plus N2.
I'll right the second
first, P of a-plus, c-plus
plus P of c-plus, b-plus.
So I didn't put specific
populations 1/3, 1/4.
But in general whatever
populations you choose,
this inequality must hold.
So that's the more
clever strategy.
Because suppose you
choose some populations
and you don't get
in trouble, well,
maybe with some
other populations
you would get in trouble.
Maybe it's not so easy to
get the relative factors.
So here is something
that must be
true whatever
populations you choose.
And now that is
Bell's inequality.
So the achievement
of Bell is to somehow
translate this assumption of
realism into an inequality.
And now quantum mechanics has
a formula for these things,
for this probability.
So we can test
whether this is true.
So let's do that.
This is the so-called
Bell inequality.
So if quantum mechanics is
true, the following should hold.
Let's see that.
If QM is true,
well, there should
be a problem with
this inequality.
So let's see what happens.
Let's see if it's
true, this inequality.
Is it really true?
Well, the left
hand side would be,
given the formula
that we had, 1/2
of the sine squared
of theta ab over 2.
So let me just
emphasize, this was
derived using local realism.
Local realism gives that.
So you do the experiment,
get these probabilities.
And if realism is
true, this should hold.
Let's see what quantum
mechanics has to say.
Let's plug-in the values that
you get from quantum mechanics.
Now we calculated
this probability.
We put the first term.
Here is sine squared of
theta ac over 2 and 1/2
of sine squared theta bc over 2.
So does that work?
Does that always work?
Can I orient this axis in
such a way to disprove EPR?
And in fact, it turns out
to be quite easy to do that.
So you choose three
vectors like this.
ac, bc, so c here, a here,
and b here, I believe.
Yep.
So put an angle theta here.
An angle theta here.
And then what do you have?
Theta ab would be 2 theta.
Theta ac would be equal to
theta bc equal to theta.
That's a pretty nice
simple choice of angles.
If you choose these
angles now, let's
see what happens
with our inequality.
So you get 1/2 sine squared
theta ab over 2 would be theta.
Is it less than
or equal to this?
Well, these two become the same.
So you get sine squared
of theta over 2.
Violated or not violated?
Is it true or false,
this, for all theta?
What do you say?
Yes?
STUDENT: If theta is less
than pi, that's not true.
PROFESSOR: Close.
It's not true for a small theta.
So if you're this, and
you're desperate to know,
the thing you have
to do is assume
theta is very, very small.
See if you get in trouble.
How much is this?
1/2 theta squared.
Let's see.
Half of this one?
Yeah.
And how much is this?
This is theta squared over 4.
Sorry, I was not seeing it.
Sine theta for small
theta is roughly theta.
So here is theta over 2 squared.
But here is 1/2 theta squared.
And it's false.
The 1/2 theta squared
is not smaller
than one quarter theta squared.
And in fact, for
theta equal pi over 2,
I think this is an equality.
Because theta equal
pi over 2, you
get on the left hand
side 1/2 less than
or equal than sine of 45
degrees, which is correct.
So it's an equality
of pi over 2.
Fails below.
So it was a shock.
That if you could do an
experiment in quantum mechanics
and experiment with correlated,
entangled particles,
that you could to measure
these probabilities,
these correlations.
And you would obtain a result
that actually contradicts
for certain alignments
of your experiments
the assumptions
of local realism.
So it was a great
result of Bell to show
that quantum mechanics
is in contradiction
with local realism.
There's no way to keep the
ideas of quantum mechanics
and put hidden
variables and assume
that there's real
values for things
and that there's no
effect at a distance.
It would all be contradicted
by an experiment.
That was done later and
the definite version
of the experiments
around 1980 or '82
by Alan Aspect and others.
Very clever experiments worth
reading and understanding.
But confirmed that the
quantum mechanical result
is really true by
measuring correlated pairs.
And this inequality is violated.
Yes?
STUDENT: So what about
David Bohm's theory
of hidden variables
quantum mechanics?
So--
PROFESSOR: David
Bohm's theory of what?
STUDENT: His hidden variable
quantum mechanics theory
allegedly reproduces the same
results as quantum mechanics
but it's still a hidden
variables theory.
PROFESSOR: I don't think there's
any hidden variable theory that
works.
David Bohm, I
think, actually was
credited by rewriting EPR,
who essentially talked
about position and momenta
to talk about spins.
And he might have been
the first one that
began to try to do
hidden variable theory.
But no hidden variable
theory works at this moment.
And this shows it.
So people say that
actually this assumes
that there's local
hidden variable theories
and there's non-local
hidden variable
theories and all kinds
of strange things.
But it's more and
more unnatural.
So it doesn't seem to do
something very interesting.
Yes, there are many questions.
Aaron, maybe you want
to say something.
STUDENT: Let's see, I think Bohm
has a non-local hidden variable
theory solution.
It's kind of awful looking.
But I guess violates the
second principle rather than
the first one.
It also doesn't extend
to-- this doesn't really
work for everything.
We don't know how to make it
work for a spin-1/2 particle
to find [? a dimension. ?] So
[INTERPOSING VOICES] really
believe to be a true theory
of [? equivalence. ?]
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
More questions.
Steve?
STUDENT: In the case with EPR,
is it a problem that we can
have scenarios where the spin
is greater than a spin-1/2
particle would have?
If we had the state
a-plus, b-plus, c-plus,
we would have 3 h bar over 2?
PROFESSOR: No.
The statement that
is done here is not
that-- well, this is a
label for a particle.
EPR just assumed
that if you measured
a you would be able to get this.
If you measure along
b, you would get this.
And if you measured along
c, you would get this.
So this is a single particle.
Any measurement gives some
results this side of the list.
There's no sense in
which these are added.
STUDENT: But even when you
measure one or the other,
the other values still exist
for those measurements.
PROFESSOR: Well,
I believe there's
no need to discuss that.
So they don't talk
about the statement
of doing subsequent measurements
within this statement.
You just take this
particle and you decide.
You measure a or
measure b or measure c.
You don't try to
measure simultaneously.
You don't try to measure
one after another.
You just do one measurement.
And that already, which
is the minimum you can do,
gets you in trouble.
So I'm not sure how EPR would
phrase subsequent measurements
after they've done
the first measurement
or things like that.
But they're not
necessary for this stage.
OK, so look, it's a
very interesting thing.
There's lots to discuss here,
but it's best if you read it.
James had a question.
Just let's take
one quick question.
STUDENT: I was just wondering
if there was any other extension
beyond three directions
for Bell's inequalities.
Is there a N-direction
of Bell's inequalities
or some type of form of it?
Or is there [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There are other
forms of Bell inequalities.
I'm not sure if it's
popular with four
directions or anything.
But certainly Weinberg, for
example, discuss other ways.
There are alternative
ways to phrase it.
I've talked about
here probabilities
to observe results.
There is a more,
perhaps, [? common ?] way
talking about expectation
values or correlation functions.
This is something you'll
do in the homework.
The sort of game that is
done in the homework that
was a suggestion by Aaron
to put it in the homework--
this game in which with quantum
strategy and entangled pair
you beat the system-- is yet
another formulation of the Bell
inequalities as well.
So lot to do.
But I think it's better
now that we stop and talked
about angular momentum from now
until the end of the semester.
This was about spins,
but we now have
to put together angular
momentum which is orbital
and spin and all
the various kinds.
So we'll begin with
angular momentum.
So there are notes
on the web on that
that I wrote and modified
a little this time.
And lots of little exercises.
So what I want to
do now is guide you
through the things that
happen there so that you
get a view of what
we're going to do.
We're going to work with this
thing in a elegant way using
vector notation for
operators is going
to help us understand
things better.
So we've seen angular
momentum before.
And let me summarize simple
things that we know about it.
If you have angular momentum,
and let's begin with orbital.
This is what we have when we
take Lx to be y Pz minus z Py.
Ly equals z Px minus x Pz.
And Lz to be equal
to x Py minus y Pz.
These are the angular momentum,
orbital angular momentum
operators.
Now, it's better for
many things to use labels
like x, y, and z,
those operators.
Call them x1 hat,
x2 hat, x3 hat.
And Px, Py, Pz, P1, P2, P3.
In that way you can write
commutation relations like xi,
Pj equal i h bar delta ij.
xi with xj equal
pi with pj equal 0.
So it allows you to write
things more quickly.
In fact, the angular
momentum operators
become also a little simpler.
It's sort of x2 P3 minus x3 P2.
And you'll have the x,
y, z labels and all that.
So we want to use
vector notation.
Now, vector notation, you
can do it in two ways.
You can talk about triplets.
Those are vectors.
Or you can form the
vectors themselves.
Now if you form the
vectors, you get
objects that sometimes are
a little disconcerting.
But we try that they not be so.
So here is the r
vector operator.
You could think of it as
the triplet of x, y, and z.
But let's call it like this,
x thing times the first basis
vector plus y operator times
the second basis vector
plus z operator times
the third basis vector.
And we've done things like that.
And we understand that
these basis vectors really
don't talk with these operators.
They can be moved
across each other.
The basis vectors
are things that
help you write
expressions, rather,
at talking about triplets.
Same thing for momentum.
Let's do it this way.
P1 e1 plus P2 e2 plus P3 e3.
And finally, well, angular
momentum, the vector operator--
you've done a lot of the
angular momentum vector operator
for spin.
So here you would put Lx or
L1 e1 plus L2 e2 plus L3 e3.
So those are ways
to write equations
that carry all the operators
and treat them as vectors, even
though they're operators.
So they're unusual vectors.
They're vectors whose components
are operators, are not numbers.
So the obvious question
is, what changes then?
So we're going to define
dot product and cross
products as we had before.
But we have to be a little aware
that when we write these things
we could make a mistake
unless we're not careful.
So here are two
vector operators.
What is the dot product of
these two vector operators?
Well, you know it's supposed to
be the first component of this
and the first component of that,
second second, third third.
So it should be ai bi, summed.
Repeated in this is
our [? summed. ?]
Now, I should not write
bi ai with a reverse order
because this thing, the
components, are now operators.
And maybe they don't commute.
So I've defined this once
and for all to be this.
And a cross b, the i-th
component of this thing
is going to be defined
once and for all
to be epsilon ijk aj bk.
Definition.
The a to the left of the b.
And with this, we can
check our usual rules
of manipulation of operators.
So one more definition.
a squared is going to be aa,
and it's going to be ai ai.
Simplest calculation is a
dot b equals to b dot a.
Yes or not?
No, they're operators.
So let's calculate
the difference.
Let's get a little practice
calculating differences.
So I write a dot b is
equal to ai bi, its sum.
So then I say, that's
ai bi plus bi ai.
You see the commutator
is ai bi minus bi ai.
And I add it back.
But this thing,
bi ai is b dot a.
So here I've got a formula.
a dot b is equal, actually, to
b dot a plus this commutator,
ai bi.
And now you've got a new formula
for operator vector analysis.
a dot b and b dot
a are not the same
but they differ by this thing.
And a very important corollary,
very famous corollary,
what is r dot p?
Is it the same as p dot r?
If you're working
quantum mechanics
you maybe tempted to, oh r dot
p and p dot r are the same,
but r and p don't commute,
so what is the difference?
R dot p is equal to
p dot r plus xi pi.
And how much is that?
[INAUDIBLE]
Sorry?
STUDENT: i h bar.
PROFESSOR: i h bar?
STUDENT: 3.
PROFESSOR: 3 i h bar.
Yes, don't forget the sum.
This is supposed to be summed.
So it says x1 commutative,
p1, x2 going to 3 i h bar.
So here's a famous formula.
rp differs from pr plus three h
bar i-- i h bar, people write.
i h bar.
Another formula that you
would be curious to know.
Well, the dot product was
supposed to be symmetric.
It's not.
The cross product is
supposed to be antisymmetric.
Is it or not?
a cross b sub i is equal
to epsilon ijk aj bk.
What do I do next?
I want to move the
a and b's around.
So I'm going to replace
this by a commutator
plus the other ordering, ijk.
And I put here-- well, this
would be a parentheses-- aj bk
commutator plus bk aj.
Now, what do we get?
Well, you have to look
at the second term.
Let's put the first term here
because that's-- pretty much,
we're not going to be
able to do much with it.
aj bk.
And the first term, I
would write it like this.
Minus epsilon, flip
these two, ikj bk aj.
If you do it like
that, then it sort of
fits nicely with the definition
of the cross product.
Because in the cross product,
the first label those here,
the second label goes with the
last labeled of the epsilon.
So this thing is
minus b cross a.
And that was a cross b.
Plus epsilon ijk aj bk.
So that's your formula for
of how the cross product.
Now fails to be antisymmetric.
It's not necessarily
antisymmetric
unless you're lucky.
So here is a property that
you should try to think about.
How about r cross r?
Is it 0 or not 0?
r cross r.
You could say,
what can I do here?
Well, r cross r
minus r cross r--
two r across r's should
be equal to this.
But both components are x's.
So r cross r is 0.
p cross p, that's also 0.
And therefore, say,
L cross L, is it 0?
Maybe.
Is that right?
No.
L cross L, we'll see
it a little later,
but it's not 0 because one L
with another L don't commute.
Lights, high.
OK.
So L cross L is actually not
0 because this thing is not 0.
We'll talk about
it a little later.
But actually this is
a very famous one.
L cross L is proportional
to L with an h bar.
It's a lovely formula.
So another interesting thing.
Well, what is r cross p?
r cross p, from this formula
we would minus p cross r.
And how about the other term?
Is it 0 or not 0?
Is r cross p equal to minus
p cross r, or does that fail?
Well, r and p don't commute.
Actually this formula--
I should have-- somebody
should have complained.
This should be the i-th
component, the i-th component,
and here is the i-th component.
So i-th component
the i-th component.
But then let's look at here.
Epsilon ijk xj pk.
But xj and pk is
i h bar delta jk.
Now, this delta jk is symmetric.
This is antisymmetric.
You should get accustomed
to the idea that that is 0.
If this is antisymmetric and
this is symmetric, this is 0.
Let me do it one more time.
Maybe this is not
completely obvious.
But epsilon ijk delta jk.
The intuition is also obvious.
Epsilon must have the
three numbers different
and this forces
them to be the same.
But it's more general.
If this is antisymmetric
and this is symmetric,
they should be 0.
And the way you do that is
you say relabel j and k.
Whatever was called j call it k.
Whatever was called k call it j.
So this is epsilon ikj delta kj.
And then we use the
symmetry properties.
So when you exchange this
back you get a minus sign when
you exchange this back
you don't get a sign.
So minus ijk delta jk.
So you have shown that this
thing is equal to minus itself.
And therefore it's 0.
Something that's equal
to minus itself is 0.
So this is 0.
And you've got that r cross
p is really minus p cross r.
And that's what we call the
angular momentum, r cross p.
But now you know that it's
also equal to minus p cross r.
Let's see, one other
one, for example,
that is classically true.
Let's see if it's quantum
mechanically true.
r dot L. The angular
momentum L is supposed
to be perpendicular
to r and perpendicular
to p because this is
the cross product.
Is that true quantum
mechanically or not true?
Well, maybe I didn't say--
well, we said L is r cross p.
So this is r dot r cross p.
So this would be ri times
epsilon ijk-- no, x-- xj pk.
So what is this?
It's epsilon ijk xi xj pk.
Well, this is 0 because these
two x's are operators but they
commute.
Therefore this object is
symmetrical in i and j.
This is antisymmetric.
This is 0.
So r dot L is actually 0.
How about p dot L.
Well, there's two ways
of doing that, one that
looks pretty obvious,
one that looks a little harder.
Let's do the one that
looks a little harder.
This would be pi
epsilon ijk xj pk.
So here is the temptation.
Must be 0.
Because there is a pi pk.
Symmetric in i and k.
And here's antisymmetric
in i and k.
But it's this wrong.
These are not
obviously symmetric
unless you can move them across.
And there's an x in the
middle laughing at you
and saying, beware.
This could go wrong.
So you have to be a
little more careful.
So let's be careful.
ijk and you put pi xj
pk, all our operators.
But pi with xj the commutator
would be a delta ij and that
vanishes.
So this p actually can be moved
across the x and therefore show
that the p is on the other side.
Because the epsilon is there.
So it's a lucky thing.
So pi xj pk is not
symmetrical in i and k.
But if there's an epsilon,
you're in better shape.
So here the p can be
moved. ijk xj pi pk.
And now nobody can stop you
from saying this is symmetric.
They're next to each other, they
can be moved across each other.
It's really
symmetric in i and k.
And therefore i and k
antisymmetric, this is 0.
p dot L is equal to 0 as well.
So this was a
little bit hard way.
If you had to used that L is
actually equal to p cross r,
then the p would have been next
to the p from the beginning.
And you would have
saved a little time.
The same time that it
took you to realize
that this equality is true.
So those are true equalities.
p dot L is 0.
And it's also equal to L dot p.
It's not obvious
that L and p commute.
But in this case L dot p is 0.
If you use this formula
for L, it's obvious.
r dot L is 0.
It's also equal to L dot r.
Doesn't make a difference.
It's also true as well.
So that's roughly what goes on.
Look, I would like you
to just read those pages.
It's a continuation of this.
It's about eight pages.
I leave exercises to be done.
That's in the homework.
They're of this type,
playing with it.
And this is a good thing that
you get accustomed to it.
And the material
that you need just
for the last problem
of the homework
will be covered on Monday.
And we can talk about it
in recitation tomorrow.
So that's it for today.